je le dis moi ce que j'ai vu ce week-end
j'ai vu un président macron qui a
dévoilé sa vérité il ne fera rien sur
les retraites il a annoncé qu'ils
feraient la réforme il va prendre deux
ans et demi de concertation il la fera
un peu d'habitude il ne la fera pas
cette réforme des rythmes et il j'ai vu
un président max j'ai vu un président
macron qui en corse après avoir cinq ans
méprisés tous les territoires après
avoir 5 ans refusait de parler de
l'autonomie des régions qui parce qu'il
ya des mouvements corse cède à la rue
moi je n'ai jamais cédé à la rue moi je
ne ferais pas l'autonomie sous la
pression moi je ferai un grand mouvement
de libération des énergies des
territoires pour tous mais certainement
pas sous la pression de la menace vous
voyez nous avons un président du zig zag
un président immobile dont le seul
message c'est réaliser moi il n'est pas
de droite les français veulent les
vraies solutions de la droite le retour
à l'ordre avec des peines minimales avec
des peines planchers des entreprises en
faire bien passe pour les personnes qui
ont autorité si les français veulent les
réformes indispensables pour arrêter de
gaspiller et leur rendre juste l'argent
si les français va leur art
revalorisation du travail la vraie eh
bien ils doivent voter quelques
relâchements candidat contre moi s'il
vous plaît et dimanche le sujet c'est
l'avenir de la france c'est qu'elle
francs s'ils veulent une france en ordre
dans la rue aux frontières une france
libre de toute cette bureaucratie une
france décentralisée efficace avec un
état qui lâchent prise une france qui
revalorise le travail et qui permet de
financer sa protection sociale qui lutte
contre les gaspillages la france des
générations futures celle qui monsieur
lang leers ne laissera pas une dette
abyssale à mes enfants des personnes
sauf moi ne parle ces sujets parce que
la candidate de la droite c'est moi et
pas les usurpateurs qui essayent de sa
preuve de de s'approprier canton et
pétainiste on n'est pas gaulliste mais
quand on est d'extrême droite eh bien on
est poutine east voilà mais la vérité